[Music]
audrey has changed a lot since we first
saw her flash her picture-perfect smile
across the screen but not exactly in a
good way will she turn out to be as
wicked as Hades in uma for her will she
somehow give them both a run for their
money
we'll find out soon enough but for now
let's find out who Audrey really is and
what her motives are
when it comes to wanting to be the
fairest of them all Audrey puts the evil
queen to shame
Audrey's the daughter of Prince Phillip
and Princess Aurora who are the
protagonists of the classic Disney movie
Sleeping Beauty Audrey was raised to be
a little Miss Perfect she was given the
most beautiful gowns praised by her
grandmother and given a place in the
spotlight to say that Audrey got used to
being the queen bee would be an
understatement
so whenever Audrey's title gets
challenged she does her best to
eliminate the competition when we first
meet Audrey at the beginning of
descendants it's clear that she's not
happy to be meeting the vks welcome to
our dime trev not only is the daughter
of her mother's mortal enemy now
attending auradon prep but her boyfriend
Ben is totally smitten by her Audrey
doesn't miss a beat and she's quick to
point out that the VIII case have been
stripped of their royal titles within
ten seconds of meeting Audrey it's
obvious that she's got a hidden agenda a
purse leave dating the future king of
auradon is a pretty big deal especially
since it means that you might one day be
queen by now we all know that Audrey was
determined to be crowned the official
ruler of the United States of auradon
however her plans came crashing down
when Ben dumped her after winning a
tourney match and declared his love for
mal instead of dealing with her emotions
Audrey chose to keep up with appearances
so she immediately started dating Chad
charming to get back at then which um
didn't work to say the least
Audrey's attitude is rotten to the core
she's extremely vain and won't hesitate
to throw someone under the bus as long
as it makes her look good instead of
being happy for her best friends Lonnie
and Jane after mal gave them gorgeous
makeovers Audrey was totally fuming
turns out Audrey doesn't want anyone
looking better than her especially not
her friends
Audrey is so used to being the center of
attention that she's willing to claw her
way into the spotlight
before Melanie be transferred to auradon
prep Audrey was the girl everyone wanted
to be however things quickly changed
when the fashionable Evie and the
gorgeous Mouse started giving her a
title a run for its money there's no
doubt about it
Audrey is a beautiful girl she has
magnificent hair a killer smile amazing
skin and she looks pretty in pink but
the fact that she feels threatened by
Mouse presence just goes to show how
insecure she really is
it looks like audrey has some growing up
to do but whether she chooses to take
the high road is solely up to her with
the way things ended in the first
descendants film we were under the
impression that Audrey had learned to
accept the vks after proving themselves
to be good people mal edj and Carlos
were welcomed into Oregon with open arms
instead of being jealous
Audrey seemed to be on board she was
showcased dancing and singing along to
the set it off musical number with a
huge smile on her face so it appeared as
though Audrey had denounced her
holier-than-thou attitude and made peace
with mal and Ben however it's possible
that Audrey was just embracing the
spotlight before returning to her old
devices Audrey doesn't make an
appearance in descendants - however
she's mentioned quite a lot we find out
through Jane that Audrey is at a spa
retreat with flora fauna and
Merryweather and it's soon revealed that
Chad was dumped by Audrey soon after the
events of the first descendants film
transpired it turns out that Audrey
wasn't really into Chad she just wanted
to make Ben Jealous which isn't exactly
news whether Audrey was truly out of spa
is up for debate but we wouldn't put it
past her to be cooking up a master plan
it's no secret that Chad's got it bad
for Audrey she's the girl of his dreams
and according to Audrey he can keep on
dreaming Chad made it painfully clear
that Audrey isn't into him because his
name is Prince Chad not King Chad and
that title makes all the difference this
tidbit of information is pretty
essential because it confirms that
Audrey doesn't really love Ben she loves
what he could have offered her Audrey
wants to be the queen and she'll stop at
nothing to make her own dreams come true
but what is she really up to one look at
Audrey is all you need to know that that
girl's got something brewing in the
darkest corners of her mind before the V
case came to auradon audrey was the
prettiest and the most popular the most
envied and the most likely to succeed
but the captain of the cheerleading
squad just couldn't hold her titles and
it's quite possible that being dumped by
then in front of the entire school
seriously bruised her inflated ego so
what do villains do when they've been
scorned they get even or take things up
a notch
that's what at the end of descendants
Chadd receives a distress call from
Audrey right before the cotillion begins
it's a distress call and chat is more
than willing to be Audrey's knight in
shining armor so instead of going to the
cotillion
Chad heads towards the Sherwood Forest
to help Audrey with her car troubles but
whether or not
Audrey's distress call was staged is a
question many descendants fans have
asked themselves descendants three is
slated to air in the summer of 2019 and
it looks like Audrey might just be
playing the villain pictures of an evil
looking Audrey and a terrified Chad have
been circulating the internet and it
looks as though audrey has a very wicked
plan up her sleeve
Audrey's delicate look has been replaced
with a much edgier vibe she's seen
holding Maleficent sceptre while wearing
the missing crown so it's quite possible
that Audrey's the one who stole these
items from the Museum of cultural
history audrey has always had a mean
streak about her she was raised under
the premise that she was better than
everyone especially the vks so the fact
that she was vested by mal totally
messed with her mind we just hope she'll
have the good sense to let bygones be
bygones
before she winds up being the queen of
the Isle of the Lost
so do you guys think Audrey is rotten to
the core or is she simply going through
a rough patch in her life let us know in
the comments section below
and that's a wrap thanks for watching
the things we hope you liked our video
give it a big thumbs up if you're
excited for descendant 3 for the latest
descendants news be sure to hit that
subscribe button we'll see you next time
[Music]